in the case of a person who vomits
intentionally or
unintentionally is the ruling the same
regarding whether or not it invalidates
the fast as far as vomiting is concerned
I beloved Prophet M said it's a say had
which appears
in in the book of fasting Hadith number
720 I beloved Prophet said that anyone
who vomits involuntarily then should not
make up for the fast but the person who
vomits voluntarily vomits deliberately
then he has to make up for the Fast and
the same Hadith is repeated in Sunan Abu
da volume number two in the book of
fasting Hadith number 2374 our beloved
Prophet said that anyone who vomit
suddenly that means involuntary suddenly
then he should not atone for it that
means the fast is valid you should not
make up for it but anyone whoit
deliberately then he should atone for it
that means he has to make a further fast
later so if someone vomits
unintentionally the
fast is not invalidated he can complete
the fast but someone vomit deliberately
like putting a finger in his throat and
vomiting or pressing his stomach and
vomiting or purposely smelling something
which is very nasty and continues doing
that and then he vomits or he looks at
something which is undesirable and he
keeps on looking at it continuously and
then vomits so all these come under the
act of deliberately vomiting if you
vomit deliberately then you have to make
up for the fast if it's unintentionally
but if the vomit comes to your mouth and
then you again swallow it that will
break the fast so the vomit comes out
involuntary let the vomit come out don't
suppress it then the fast not broken but
if it comes and then you swallow the
vomit back into your stomach that will
break the fast yes if you again swallow
the vomit which has come out the vit
comes out let the vomit come out
involuntary that will not be the
fast
e
e e